[Música]
fuertes bombardeos han tenido lugar en
Ucrania las tropas rusas lanzaron
decenas de misiles de crucero desde el
mar Negro el objetivo la infraestructura
eléctrica de regiones como gif poltaba
vinitza y vano francops odesa entre
otras tantas el saldo pues hasta el
momento decenas de víctimas mortales y
miles de personas en todo Ucrania han
quedado sin suministro de energía y
otros servicios básicos el panorama
general de lo que ha sucedido en la
jornada de hoy en Ucrania lo vemos en el
siguiente informe preparado por la
redacción de France 24
los residentes de este barrio de kiev
tuvieron un duro despertar ventanas
rotas vehículos destruidos junto a los
edificios
los bomberos no escatimaron esfuerzos
durante la noche una impresionante
lluvia de misiles rusos y drones
kamikaces golpeó la capital ucraniana
los residentes están en estado de shock
oí una explosión muy fuerte rápidamente
saltamos de la cama y vimos un coche en
llamas luego los demás coches también se
incendiaron
es difícil explicar lo que siento un
metro a la izquierda o a la derecha y
podría haber sido mi apartamento no
tengo palabras
estos bombardeos rusos los mayores desde
hace seis semanas han matado a varias
personas diez regiones ucranianas han
sido golpeadas entre ellas lip en el
oeste que no había sido golpeada hasta
ahora ni Pro Nicolás o saporiya donde la
mayor central nuclear del país quedó
desconectada de la red nacional
numerosas instalaciones energéticas
también han sido atacadas en toda
Ucrania dejando a millones de hogares
sin electricidad la novedad de estos
ataques calificados de tácticas
miserableski es el uso por parte de
Rusia de al menos seis misiles
hipersónicos kinghal un arma que kiev no
tiene forma de derribar porque el
kinghal vuela al menos dos veces más
rápido que los misiles dedicados a su
defensa antiaérea según los expertos
Moscú dispone de varias decenas de estos
misiles hipersónicos
estos ataques aéreos ocurrieron cuando
la atención internacional estaba en esa
intensa batalla por el control de la
ciudad de bahamut en donde Los
mercenarios del grupo Wagner indicaron
que han conquistado parte del este de
esa ciudad pese a la resistencia que ha
habido por parte de las tropas
ucranianas bahamut se convirtió Entonces
en ese nuevo botín a conquistar y Cuál
es la importancia porque es importante
capturar la ciudad de bahamut los
combates en esta ciudad han sido los más
intensos en los últimos meses desde que
comenzó este conflicto o esta invasión
de Rusia al territorio ucraniano A qué
responde Rusia Entonces ha utilizado su
máxima capacidad militar en este
conflicto es decir hemos visto la cara
más oscura en términos militares de lo
que puede hacer la federación en
términos militares hoy en el debate de
France 24 hacemos entonces una
actualización de los hechos más
recientes en Ucrania y para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a filipi
Vasconcelos él es profesor de la
Universidad Autónoma de Lisboa se
conecta desde la capital portuguesa
desde la Ciudad de México en México se
conecta Genaro veristaín él es profesor
de política internacional en la UNAM y
en el Tec de Monterrey y aquí en el
estudio de France 24 nos acompaña Luis a
María Lozano ella es profesora de
relaciones internacionales y también es
directora del programa de ciencias
políticas de la Universidad de la sabana
en Bogotá en Colombia a los tres les
agradezco por estar con nosotros aquí en
el programa de recuerdo también a
ustedes nuestros televidentes que
ustedes también son parte de este debate
de esta conversación pueden dejar todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales estamos en Twitter
en Facebook en instagram ustedes ya lo
ya lo saben nos encuentran como arroba
franz24- bajo s la etiqueta para que
dejen los comentarios es numeral el
debate f24 y a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como arroba santilogo ya para
terminar de recuerdo también que todos
los contenidos del programa también
están disponibles en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces con Luis amarilla aquí
en el estudio de France 24 Luisa María
Bienvenida al programa Gracias por estar
con nosotros y
toca comenzar preguntándole por lo que
significa estos ataques estos bombardeos
recientes que ha perpetrado el ejército
Ruso y Los mercenarios de Wagner en
diferentes puntos de la geografía
ucraniana Muchas gracias Santiago por la
invitación Mire lo que sucedió esta
madrugada sin duda es un mensaje claro
de Rusia lo que está pasando en la
región de batmut los ha golpeado
muchísima emocionalmente y también
reputacionalmente como país se estamos
se están preguntando los analistas será
que este es el fin de El potencial
militar de Rusia en Ucrania si no ganan
esta región Tal vez están empezando a
perder la guerra entonces Creo que este
este bombardeos son un mensaje claro de
Aquí estamos y aquí nos vamos a quedar
tenemos la tecnología suficiente para
vulnerar ese escudo antimisiles de
Ucrania tenemos la infraestructura
suficiente para quebrar la electricidad
el suministro de gas perjudicar a la
población fíjese que los ataques no
dejan muchos muertos claro cada muerte
es muy significativa pero no es en
magnitud atacaron unos puntos muy claves
que terminan perjudicando
significativamente a la población y esto
genera pues obviamente en la opinión
pública un impacto importante entonces
creo que Rusia es también un mensaje de
todavía tenemos Con qué luchar a pesar
de que en algunos puntos no estamos
obteniendo los resultados que tenemos
que Precisamente es como usted lo
mencionaba en la región de batmut donde
estamos viendo una guerra totalmente
diferente no tan tecnológica sino casi
de trincheras estamos volviendo como un
escenario muy de Primera Guerra Mundial
exactamente pero tenemos la tecnología
para romper el escudo ante misiles de
Ucrania entonces creo que esto es un
mensaje muy claro que le envía al mundo
decir tenemos todavía con que luchar
esta guerra ahí con qué luchar y le dejo
la pregunta sobre la mesa para responder
la más adelante es si esta capacidad que
tiene es suficiente para conquistar y
para sacar ventaja en la guerra pasó a
preguntarle a Genaro en la Ciudad de
México también sus impresiones de lo que
dejan estos combates estos ataques
perpetrados por Rusia cuando estábamos
enfocados en Back mood en el minuto a
minuto en metro por metro que ganaba
cada una de las partes en esta guerra
como ha dicho Luisa María casi que una
guerra de trincheras que análisis hace
usted
Bueno a mí me parece que puede llegar a
empantanarse nuevamente el conflicto ahí
en macmut no encuentro yo
una Bueno una relación táctica
significativa que pueda llevar a cabo un
golpe de vuelta hacia o que favorezca a
la federación rusa creo que están
desgastando muchísimas tropas y que está
haciendo una carnicería sin sentido la
toma de badmur el grupo Wagner Parece
ser que tiene localizado y controlado el
este y el sur de la ciudad pero yo estoy
viendo cómo se está repitiendo la
historia y se está convirtiendo un
stalingrado en esta región entonces creo
que significativamente no tiene una gran
relevancia esta ciudad Pero
a la mejor la toma de de esta ciudad el
esfuerzo bélico que haga Rusia para
tomar esta ciudad pueda subir la moral
de sus soldados y por supuesto enseñarle
al mundo de manera propagandística que
todavía puede impulsar y continuar con
este esfuerzo bélico al menos otro año y
ahora saludamos a filipi en la ciudad de
Lisboa Felipe y la misma pregunta como
Punto de partida su análisis de estos
combates que han tenido lugar en la
jornada de hoy y esa intensa batalla en
bahamot
Hola buenas noches a los colegas de
panel y
muchas gracias por la invitación Bueno
yo creo que estamos disputando y Rusia
está disputando dos guerras a la vez al
menos dos guerras claves la primera Es
sobre el terreno esa guerra de
trincheras que ya fue mencionada una
guerra casi decimonónica en el sentido
tradicional del término parece que
volvimos en determinados momentos a la
Primera Guerra Mundial ni ni es la
segunda la Primera Guerra Mundial una
guerra de Infantería que se está
disputando más al este Pero hay también
el gran conflicto que está subyacente a
todo este a toda esta guerra que es el
conflicto entre Rusia y occidente y en
ese contexto los bombardeos a distintos
puntos de la geografía ucraniana tienen
que leerse más en el sentido de la señal
que es enviada para el occidente que
está muy involucrado en el apoyo a
Ucrania involucrado no solo del punto de
vista financiero pero también de las
armas que está trasladando a Ucrania o
en Europa el debate continúa en términos
de de los de los tanques de combate que
están de los leopard que están siendo
ofertados por alemán y también Portugal
tres leoparban de Portugal para para
fortalecer las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas y Y estos bombardeos de esta
señal de vida que Rusia da en distintas
partes del territorio en mi opinión
deben ser leídas Sobre todo como una
señal para este este apoyo que occidente
va dando a Ucrania y Felipe continuó con
usted para hacer la ronda en sentido
contrario y le pregunto por qué Rusia se
ve entonces en la necesidad de hacer
este tipo de bombardeos este tipo de
acciones cuando prácticamente Ya está
empezando a controlar la ciudad de
bakmuth que es donde estaban
concentrados los ataques y donde estaba
concentrada Prácticamente la actividad
de la guerra está notando Rusia que está
notando el kremlin y al presidente Putin
que se ve en la necesidad de armar
digamos este espectáculo para llamar la
atención de la comunidad internacional y
volverles a decir acá estoy con mis
misiles hipersónicos
bueno en primer lugar
si si miramos a largo plazo si miramos
de a un año hasta ahora lo que ocurrió
es que los objetivos iniciales de Rusia
no lograron ser
llegar concretizados y por eso es
necesario que Putin va dando señales de
que tiene potencia que tiene fuego y que
sus fuerzas armadas nos están
desestructurando esto no me parece que
esté ocurriendo pero efectivamente los
objetivos que
trazó en febrero del 2022 una tomada
rápida de Ucrania con una mudanza de
régimen por ejemplo con un intento de
toma de la capital kiev no fue no fue
alcanzado y en ese sentido hay que dar
periódicamente señales con armas con
instrumentos con una proyección de una
imagen tecnológica que pueden ser una
señal sobre todo cuando Comparado con
las armas que occidente va a estar está
trasladando a Ucrania puede venir a
trasladar un apunte un apunte apenas no
podemos olvidar que en Siria por ejemplo
Rusia intentó proyectar una imagen de
alguna competitividad tecnológica con el
occidente pero lo que acabamos de ver en
esta guerra en este año de guerra es que
Rusia no consiguió mantener esa imagen Y
que está por ejemplo en el terreno
luchando con tanques que tienen que son
casi del periodo en la Segunda Guerra
Mundial Genaro continuó con usted ya le
doy la palabra Luisa María Genaro Por
qué a Rusia cada paso en este conflicto
le está costando tanto supuestamente es
una potencia militar es una potencia si
lo comparamos en términos de las fuerzas
militares con Ucrania porque cada paso
en este conflicto se vuelve a un punto
en donde se estanca el conflicto lo
vimos en Mario Paul en en saporilla lo
estamos viendo ahora en Back mood
los ucranianos están dando la batalla
eso ya lo sabemos con el apoyo de
occidente Pero porque a Rusia le está
costando tanto
Bueno creo que podríamos establecer dos
principales razones la primera Es que no
entiendo muy bien la razón pero Tal
parece que las fuerzas convencionales
bueno tenemos un problema con la señal
de Genaro en Ciudad de México
retomaremos la conexión con el más
adelante continúa aquí en el estudio con
Luisa María haciendo el análisis
habíamos dejado una pregunta sobre la
mesa Luisa María y es y Rusia
verdaderamente tiene la capacidad para
lograr ganar la guerra Esto va un poco
en línea con la pregunta que le estaba
haciendo a Genaro de porque cada paso
cuesta tanto si supuestamente tiene la
capacidad militar porque no es más
contundente Sí yo creo que también es
parte de la imagen que nos ha proyectado
Rusia que tiene esa capacidad militar Y
en teoría Debería ser muy fácil ganarle
a Ucrania y no lo ha podido hacer porque
creo que han fallado mucho también en la
parte estratégica subestimaron lo que
podía suceder en el territorio ucraniano
creo que en principio lo que quería
hacer el presidente Putin era una Guerra
Relámpago en la que pudiera tomar el
territorio muy rápido conquistar y salir
pero definitivamente no pasó entonces
creo que se subestimó un poco al
adversario y segundo pues respondido tal
vez de la forma no ven que Ucrania
esperaba pero le ha podido suministrar
estrategia algo que es muy importante
inteligencia Y pues las armas que sin
duda le ha ido suministrando en estos
meses lo cual casi que cada semana va
renovando renovando su armamento y
también algo de capacidad militar le ha
dado entonces creo que está habilitado
mucho a Rusia ahora si tiene la
capacidad para ganar la guerra creo que
es una pregunta Que que muchos nos
hacemos Yo creo que esto puede ser un
conflicto que se puede extender por
varios años tal y como lo estamos viendo
se está convirtiendo casi que en una
guerra de desgaste en la que estamos
perdiendo hombres diariamente sobre todo
lo que está pasando en bakmut y estamos
dando algunos impactos como los que
pasaron hoy pero se vuelven más impactos
mediáticos por enviar un mensaje como
decía el profesor anteriormente pero
realmente no vemos un avance
significativo nada de los 81 misiles que
se lanzaron hoy pretendían conquistar
territorio claro piense que no no tenían
esa intención simplemente tenían esa
intención de enviar un mensaje de tengo
la militar Pero qué es capacidad militar
Realmente si es ganar una guerra Rusia
no la tiene en este momento una cosa es
tener mucho armamento y muchos soldados
y otros realmente la capacidad que me
implica poder doblegar a mi enemigo
poder llegar estratégicamente y creo
conquistar exactamente o lograr los
objetivos que al menos teníamos
propuestos Y eso no está pasando
entonces creo que una cosa es el poder
militar que tenga y otra la capacidad
militar que definitivamente no se está
demostrando la capacidad militar pues ya
está en duda lo que sí tenemos claro es
que tiene capacidad nuclear que eso
siempre está sobre la mesa por las
amenazas que lanza el kremlin cada dos
por tres a la comunidad internacional
Genaro Ya lo tenemos de vuelta otra vez
con nosotros bienvenida otra vez
adelante Muchas gracias Perdón bueno
básicamente yo quería Construir mi
argumento en dos razones principales la
primera básicamente es precisamente el
apoyo que ha ejercido o que ha dado la
comunidad internacional entiéndase
Estados Unidos y sus aliados en Europa
hay alrededor de
bueno seguimos teniendo problemas
técnicos hoy la tecnología no está dado
de de nuestro lado para para el programa
pero vamos a retomar la conexión con
Genaro más adelante quiero entonces
preguntarle a Felipe en la ciudad de
Lisboa en Portugal y aquí lo podemos
construir entre los invitados que
tenemos porque esta importancia de Back
mood cuando es una ciudad que está
simplemente en el este En la región de
donietsk región que es una pues donde se
ha concentrado los combates y el
desplazamiento de los militares Pero qué
es Back mood Por qué es importante
cuando uno ve otros centros urbanos
ucranianos de mayor importancia Como por
ejemplo saporilla por tener la central
nuclear allí o los puertos la ciudad de
mariopol el puerto de Odessa por ejemplo
que ha sido una ciudad que prácticamente
no ha tocado Rusia a lo largo de estos
combates Aunque en los bombardeos de hoy
sí hubo puntos en la región de Odessa no
en la ciudad que fueron impactados por
estos
misiles Bueno si si vamos al inicio de
este conflicto este conflicto empieza en
el 2014 No ahora no no olvidemos que en
2014 Rusia muy rápidamente toma la
crimea que era un territorio étnicamente
Ruso y que tenía un precurso histórico
totalmente distinto del resto del
territorio ucraniano pero también
concentra sus esfuerzos en apoyar los
independentistas de donetsky y y el
punto es justo este es que al no lograr
tampoco la totalidad de los territorios
de los que son las provincias de
herodesk y lugans esto demuestra la
incapacidad de Rusia de de llegar a los
objetivos más maximalistas que había
establecido en febrero del 2022 y este
es el desafío hablábamos de Odessa pero
los rusos no consiguen llegar a odes hoy
día y Odessa tiene un aspecto
estratégico del punto de vista comercial
porque no podemos olvidar también que
mientras rusos y ucranianos siguen
teniendo un mínimo múltiple común de
acuerdo que tiene que ver con la
componente comercial de los cereales y
también de los fertilizantes pero lo que
la la incapacidad de tomar la totalidad
de donets y lugares que demuestra la
incapacidad después de un año de
combates de un año de incursión de
inversión masiva de los recursos
financieros rusos y también de los
recursos humanos de sus jóvenes la
incapacidad de lograr los mínimos que
sería la consolidación de lo que empezó
en 2014 sí retomamos la conexión con
Genaro la tercera la vencida Genaro Aquí
vamos de nuevo y le quiero preguntar
porque tengo que mirar la otra cara de
la moneda hemos hablado que tal vez
Rusia tiene no están contundentes sus en
sus ataques y no ha podido concretar
al 100% su operación militar pero
también hay analistas que dicen no
subestimen a Rusia Porque todavía no
hemos visto el 100% de lo que Rusia
puede dar en terreno de combate estamos
simplemente viendo la punta del iceberg
con el lanzamiento de estos misiles y
hipersónicos de Última Generación que
lanzaron en los ataques de hoy estamos
subestimando a Rusia
Perdón por las fallas en la conexión
adelante bueno con respecto a su
pregunta no está yo no estaría tan
seguro de que sea la punta de la iceberg
creo que ha cometido ciertos errores
Rusia pero por el otro lado
no sé por qué no ha utilizado sus
fuerzas profesionales ha mandado a los
jóvenes he utilizado el grupo Wagner en
los combates
si si hay por ahí una razón No sabría yo
cuál es la estrategia final el ejército
profesional y bien preparado de Rusia no
se le ha visto mucho en el teatro de
operaciones por otro lado Rusia tiene
aliados y entre ellos está Corea del
Norte y el sistema de misiles de Corea
del Norte pues es uno de los más
sofisticados a nivel internacional Rusia
también puede hacer eco y el apoyo de
China y de la India en la compra de su
petróleo y de su gas natural entonces
este pues no efectivamente no debemos
subestimar a Rusia pero en el teatro de
operaciones el desgaste puede ser
contraproducente por otro lado pues
Ucrania ha recibido bastante ataque o
las vidas de los ucranianos se han
estado perdiendo Lamentablemente y hay
reportes de que ahora quienes están en
este en defendiendo la ciudad pues son
jóvenes y ancianos esto quiere decir que
va a llegar un punto en que Ucrania se
va a quedar sin adultos este que puedan
contener la ofensiva rusa que eso
claramente afectará la defensa y
cambiará un poco el juego de la guerra
si esta guerra como dice Luisa María se
extiende y se prolonga en el tiempo que
es lo que la mayoría de los analistas
estiman en este combate que sea una
guerra de desgaste tengo que escalar
esto un poco más a la escena
internacional porque hay varios puntos
importantes para destacar y para
analizar la raíz de los hechos que han
tenido lugar en Ucrania en las últimas
en las últimas horas y es también la
atención que hay en moldavia y en la
región de transnistria hubo también unas
unas denuncias desde diferentes sectores
en la República
autoproclamada República de transnistria
de un posible atentado terrorista allí
perpetrado por inteligencia ucraniana
kiev lo desmintió Rusia había advertido
desde febrero este supuesto ataque a
ustedes estas versiones encontradas
entre tiraspol kiev y Moscú o es parte
de la jugada
rusa para desviar la atención un poco de
lo que está sucediendo en backmore y
desviarlo un poco a llevar la atención
hacia atrás nistria Mire yo sí yo sí
creo que que esto se está jugando en
varios frentes esto no solo se está
librando en un campo de batalla hoy
Rusia lo demostró envía otros ataques y
por supuesto que está movilizando sus
fichas en regiones aledañas y con otros
países digamos que es una forma también
que tienen ellos porque que de la forma
militar están perdiendo mucho terreno y
los ojos de la comunidad internacional
están empezando a cuestionar la
capacidad de Rusia realmente Y eso en
realidad lo pone no solo en riesgo
frente a sus posibilidades en Ucrania
sino a sus posibilidades como como
potencia como potencia en realidad y
está poniendo en en cuestionamientos su
liderazgo en en la región de eurasia
Entonces yo creo que sí Esto hace parte
un poco de la estrategia de movilizar
estos recursos incluso no podemos
descartar que sean ataques incluso
generados por por estas mismas fuerzas
no sé rusas que estén tratando de hacer
esto pero también puede ser una jugada
que que Ucrania puede estar haciendo yo
creo que el presidente ha sido muy
estratégico en el tema de los medios
precisamente por su perfil por su
contexto y ha sabido También muy bien
manejar esta presión de de una guerra
Pero además también llevar la atención a
lo que quiere con sus visitas que que ha
hecho en Europa
quienes lo visitan la visita al
presidente Byron fue fundamental
precisamente para el apoyo ahorita que
el profesor es Genaro mencionaba china
yo yo lo pongo muy en cuestión de
realidad Cuál es ese rol de China y si
realmente Rusia podría contar contar con
ellos Rusia también se está jugando ese
prestigio frente a países como china que
dice Bueno dónde me voy a parar yo creo
que china es muy estratégica en eso De
dónde voy a estar Y dónde va a poner mis
fichas y no sé si de repente quisiera
estar tan de frente con Rusia en este
conflicto porque podría estar perdiendo
más de lo que de lo que estaría ganando
china también lo tengo en la agenda para
analizarlo en unos minutos Luis María
por supuesto le doy la palabra a Felipe
preguntándole por lo que está sucediendo
en moldavia y en transnistria esto puede
ser un distractor o puede ser una
provocación para involucrarlos en este
conflicto porque hay que decir que hay
una gran cantidad de soldados rusos que
son parte de un cuerpo de paz para
garantizar justamente la paz en
transnistria después de un conflicto que
empezó en los años 90 pero es el área de
Ucrania en donde Rusia no ha podido
llegar y sería la forma más fácil de
provocar un estallido en el conflicto
cómo lo ve usted Felipe
Sí bueno Rusia viene actuando de dos
formas desde que Putin ejerce la
presidencia en términos de política
exterior y En comparación con lo que fue
la era de Boris en primer lugar este
esta presencia más activa en el
denominado extranjero próximo o sea las
antiguas repúblicas soviéticas y donde
no logra influir como el moldavia tiene
partes del territorio como Georgia por
ejemplo donde autoproclamó potencializó
la autoproclamación de repúblicas Y esta
es una forma de crear inestabilidad en
repúblicas del Antiguo Unión soviética
que no sean tan próximas del punto de
vista político o en momentos que no sean
tan próximos y Esto va a ejercerse
cuando sea necesario para para como
maniobra de distracción y otro punto es
son las maniobras que logró
desarrollar en países occidentales como
en Italia como en Estados Unidos durante
elecciones apoyando partidos políticos
alternativos es una política exterior
activa pero es una política exterior que
no responde a los cánones occidentales o
aquello que el occidente pensó que Rusia
para lo que Rusia estaba evolucionando
en los años 90 por eso no es de extrañar
que haigan maniobras de estas en
paralelo a acciones más evidentes como
el caso de la invasión de Ucrania
importante ese punto Felipe Felipe que
se conecta desde la ciudad de Lisboa en
Portugal le doy la palabra a Genaro en
Ciudad de México
retomó el tema de Usted lo ve como una
provocación lo ve como un distractor
están intentando involucrar a moldavia
en este conflicto ahí analistas y
personas en Ucrania Incluso en Rusia que
dicen que el siguiente objetivo de Rusia
es la República de moldavia
bueno no no creo que que Rusia tenga
planeado ocupar otro país como moldavia
o yo lo que lo que más o menos estaría
vislumbrando es que sí podría buscar una
conexión ya por tierra para esto tendría
que por supuesto tomar Odessa para
llegar hacia atrásnistria y pues los
tres ministros sí se han manifestado y
si se han decantado del lado de Rusia
entonces Más allá de de invadir otro
estado aparte de Ucrania para mí es
mantener una continuidad territorial
cortarle la salida a Ucrania para el mar
Negro y una vez conectado con
transnistria pues mantener bastante
controlada la región
y hay que decir que el líder
transnistrio Bad dime krasnold selfsky
negó la existencia de una amenaza real
por parte de Ucrania que eso era lo que
había dicho el kremlin lo dijo en
febrero aler Tokio Ucrania Estaba
preparando una provocación militar
contra este territorio que hay que
aclarar es una República autoproclamada
pertenece a moldavia pero no tiene
reconocimiento internacional y en donde
la mayoría de sus habitantes son
rusoparlantes no rumano parlantes como
en el resto de moldavia seguimos
escalando este conflicto y los hechos
recientes a otro escenario internacional
porque también ha habido reacciones en
Estados Unidos y usted ya lo mencionaba
Luisa María china es un actor importante
aquí en este conflicto el departamento
de defensa de Estados Unidos ha señalado
que la empresa Estatal rusa de energía
nuclear rosatón estaría suministrando
plutonio enriquecido a China esto le
preocupa a Washington obviamente se
habla también de un posible intercambio
de armas entre Rusia y China el papel de
china aquí se está complicando y por más
que no quieren involucrarse cada vez
están más metidos en el conflicto Luisa
María Sí mire hay algo que que hay que
reconocerle siempre a China y es que
tiene muy claro un poco su rol en el
mundo y su papel y para ellos Más allá
de involucrarse a veces en los temas
políticos porque los vemos no
involucrados en estos foros
multilaterales activamente para hablar
de Derechos Humanos Por ejemplo si
priorizan mucho ese interés económico
con quién puede hacer negocios
independientemente de la condición en la
que esté ahí estoy Y eso lo hemos visto
en distintas regiones Es decir para
China de pronto esa parte política la
tienen un una segunda instancia Así que
si encuentra precisamente con estas
estas situaciones de las posibles
negociaciones de plutonio un buen Aliado
que en este momento puede estar tomando
una ventaja porque se lo puede estar
vendiendo negociando muy buen precio
precisamente por la necesidad que tiene
Rusia es muy posible que china esté
aprovechando esta oportunidad Y por
supuesto que como el segundo poder
económico más grande del mundo para
Estados Unidos esto puede representar
pues una amenaza porque definitivamente
va a estar inclinando esa balanza
internacional y le está poniendo casi
que una posición a China frente a este
conflicto sin embargo yo no diría que
china va a entrar de frente respaldando
a Rusia o al menos no es lo que
personalmente creo que vaya a pasar una
cosa es que china haga negocios con
Rusia que es algo que siempre ha hecho y
creo que lo puede separar mucho esa
parte ya política de salida decir estoy
de entrada totalmente con Rusia en este
conflicto y cuentan con todo mi apoyo mi
industria militar y demás yo creo que es
más una cuestión transaccional tal vez
lo que puede estar haciendo china pese a
las sanciones hay muchos países que
mantienen negociaciones comerciales con
con Rusia hasta Turquía están los países
del cauca Son la misma India no no sería
un actor exclusivo en ese caso pasó a
darle la palabra entonces a Genaro para
hablar de esta preocupación en
Washington esto como escalaría entonces
este conflicto a nivel internacional de
confirmarse y de salir a la luz pública
que efectivamente china está recibiendo
plutonio ruso
Bueno a mí me gustaría apuntar que a
Washington le gusta señalar con el dedo
a todos los enemigos que pueda encontrar
es una política común de Estados Unidos
Buscar enemigos hasta debajo de las
piedras y lo que está viendo Estados
Unidos es que la contención que él había
previsto en algún momento para evitar el
crecimiento económico de China esto ya
se ha desbordado ha habido al
señalamientos de de Estados Unidos de
que china planeó un inminente ataque
hacia Taiwán etcétera etcétera entonces
yo yo veo más el lado de una exageración
por parte de Estados Unidos Aunque si
Rusia estaba utilizando el la la
posibilidad de vender armamento o vender
estos insumos a China y recibir dinero
de China para continuar el conflicto
bélico en Ucrania pues no la van a dejar
pasar Esto para mí es una transacción
económica pero pues obviamente a Estados
Unidos le gusta buscar enemigos hasta
por debajo de las piedras para cerrar la
ronda Felipe en Lisboa su análisis
Bueno este este conflicto llega en un
momento en que china estaba llegando a
su maternidad como gran potencia y como
una potencia que desafiaba el poder
norteamericano estábamos terminando el
modelo el reino de la unipolaridad que
reino durante 20 años o más de 20 años
casi 30 años del post guerra fría y esto
es un desafío enorme para la política
exterior China y para china como gran
potencia como ya fue edito dicho por por
Luisa no china es una potencia que se
ASUME que se proyecta hoy día
aprovechando la globalización y por vía
de la del del comercio no es una
potencia al estilo de la Unión soviética
de los años 60 70-80 y en ese sentido
tiene una prudencia añadida que no es
compatible con lo que Genaro decía o sea
Genaro Tiene razón porque Estados Unidos
Busca proyectar una idea de China como
si fuera una nueva Unión soviética
cuando no lo es y cuando no tiene
interés en perpetuar esta guerra y es
uno de las potencias más perjudicadas
por lo que esta guerra
significa en términos de disminución del
comercio exterior del comercio
internacional en ese sentido no me
parece que sea posible que china vaya a
alinear a críticamente con Rusia no
obstante no es alguien que también venga
alinear con las posiciones occidentales
y puede que su proyección y su proyecto
de de consolidación como el Grande
potencia sea justamente ser una tercera
vía entre Rusia y occidente que le
permitiera por ese por ejemplo
patrocinar unas grandes negociaciones en
este conflicto hemos ayudado a lo largo
de este año
participación de Rusia al este de
Ucrania hemos oído constantes amenazas
nucleares por parte del kremlin tiene
cómo hacerlo sabemos del potencial
nuclear y de la gran cantidad de armas
nucleares que tiene este país herencia
de la unión soviética pero ahora no sé
cómo interpretan ustedes esta frase que
les voy a leer Estados Unidos lamenta
que China y Rusia haya colocado las
armas nucleares en el centro de sus
estrategias para contrarrestar el poder
estadounidense y de sus aliados esto se
puede tomar como una alerta una amenaza
un llamado de atención simplemente
haciendo Ojitos a esas a esas constantes
amenazas del kremlin Luisa María yo no
creo directamente que sea una amenaza yo
creo que y lo que Leo de ese mensaje que
usted menciona Es que además Estados
Unidos está poniendo como el centro de
la controversia Pone pone la guerra en
Ucrania como un ataque directo hacia
hacia ese poder y yo creo que parte de
lo que decía el profesor Felipe es esa
amenaza que está sintiendo Estados
Unidos como una potencia hegemónica está
perdiendo campo en en el mundo realmente
no ha podido contener efectivamente lo
que está pasando en Ucrania y claramente
es muy fácil poner un enemigo y decir
este país está dispuesto a usar las
armas nucleares y nos está poniendo en
riesgo a nosotros y este sistema que
hemos protegido Durante los últimos 30
40 50 años entonces creo que en realidad
Está como dando unas patadas de ahogado
frente a una situación que que está
perdiendo y creo que que el mensaje es
más claro frente a eso y se le está
saliendo de las manos la situación me
quedan un par de minutos para finalizar
el programa Genaro hacemos las
conclusiones de lo que puede venir para
este conflicto siempre lo digo no
tenemos la bola de cristal para saber lo
que va a pasar en el futuro pero no
puede proyectar lo que puede venir en
este en este tipo de de guerras Y
también si quiere hacer algún comentario
sobre la frase que acabo de leer muy
puntual por favor
bueno Muchas gracias por la invitación
muchas gracias a mis contertulios Bueno
sí para finalizar yo sí quisiera
comentar que no se ve una salida pronta
ninguna de las dos partes está dispuesta
a sentarse a negociar podríamos esperar
fácilmente otro año de conflicto en
Ucrania y para finalizar la del
comentario Cris la frase que mencionó
pues tenemos que entender el contexto
por estar en México sabemos que se
acercan las elecciones en Estados Unidos
bueno todos claro sabemos que se acerca
a las elecciones en Estados Unidos y yo
ubico esa frase más o como para que yo
bailen esté proyectándose a un segundo
mandato
Felipe su conclusión del programa
muy muy rápidamente La con respecto a la
frase Estados Unidos comete un equívoco
al confundir Rusia con china son
estrategias distintas no son potencias
distintas pero Rusia también
demuestra su debilidad cuando llama
cíclicamente periódicamente la cuestión
nuclear para la parte de comunicación de
la guerra finalmente Creo que este año
de guerra nos ha transmitido una idea de
una mayor unidad de occidente fue un
combustible importante para recuperar la
unidad de nato de otan y también por
supuesto para generar una dinámica en
términos de la política de seguridad y
defensa de la Unión Europea Luisa María
rápidamente 10 segundos para la
conclusión Sí definitivamente esto nos
nos reconfigura un poco este mapa que
estábamos viendo como decía el profesor
Felipe creo que la otan renace un poco
pero también y para poner un punto extra
que está pasando con el multilateralismo
el rol de la ONU en realidad fue creada
para un fin y se está cuestionando mucho
si realmente puede seguir existiendo tal
y como está existiendo entonces dejo esa
esa cuestión de que está pasando con
esas organizaciones internacionales a
Felipe a Luis a María y a Genaro les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
a ustedes Muchas gracias por la sintonía
sigan con nosotros
[Música]